there was a House Judiciary Committee
hearing yesterday on reparations
Democrats want to discuss the
possibility of of preparations of a
system where presumably black people
would be paid by white people for the
sin of slavery actually this to be more
specific this this hearing was meant to
discuss a bill which would form a
commission which would conduct a study
which would look at the possibility of
reparations so that's the way everything
has to work in a bureaucracy now on the
one hand there is nothing but there's
really nothing going on there's nothing
going on here but just Democrats
throwing red meat to their to their far
left constituents the Democrat Party is
drifting well rather I should say I
guess sprinting to the left as fast as
they possibly can ever further to the
left so that today even the mainstream
figures in the party today
pretend at least to be in favor of
reparations like the Democrat
presidential candidates most of them
Cory Booker and Elizabeth Warren and
others have come out in favor of it now
remember that that it was only there's
only a few years ago that Barack Obama
when he was president came out against
reparations because all the way back
then back just a few years ago that
would have even two liberals that would
have seemed like a crazy radical idea
but as everything drifts left things
that are crazy and radical start to seem
more normal and so it's but it's
probably not gonna happen because it is
it is just throwing red meat and I think
they know that because it's not it's not
a feasible idea it's crazy it's
incredibly unpopular Rasmussen Rasmussen
did a poll and they found I think was
like 20 or 21% of people are in favor of
it only 20 or 21 percent and so it's not
a popular idea so it probably won't
happen and this is a political stunt by
the Democrats on the other hand though
if the Democrats ever have the power to
do something like this the ability to
enact something like this I think that
they there's there's a good chance that
they probably would try to do it and
besides even if this isn't something
that will happen right away
it's still worth confronting I think and
debunking because Democrats have a lot
of bad ideas it's what they're known for
and I think we should spend our time we
should we should we shouldn't ignore
them we should expose those bad ideas
and explain why they are so bad so I
want to do that with reparation
reparations today I want to talk about
why it's a crazy horrible stupid
impractical immoral idea I want to go
into detail explaining that but first
let's before we get into that let's take
a look at this hearing briefly because
there are a few things that a few a few
clips worth looking at I think the
hearing was overall as you might expect
a joke a disgrace an embarrassment and
I'm gonna play a few clips for you that
show that will start with Danny Glover
now the Dems brought Danny Glover in to
testify in favor of reparations and they
could not have possibly picked a worse
spokesman for the issue Glover is of
course a famous Hollywood actor who's
worth about forty million dollars his
net worth then is four hundred times
greater than the national median which
is a which is a little bit less than a
hundred thousand dollars and even that
is pretty high because that's you know
that's that's weighed by the people in
the upper income brackets but if you
want to look at the you know the average
income of somebody in the middle class
for instance fifty or sixty thousand
well Danny Glover is worth forty million
dollars but his distant relative was a
slave so under reparations Danny Glover
a man in the top half percent of all
income earners would be paid and the
money paid to him would be extracted
from white people most of whom are quite
a bit poorer than his that he is that of
course would be a travesty that would
literally be the rich taking from the
poor that would be I mean that would
mean that a poor white guy living in a
trailer park somewhere would have his
money taken from him and given to Danny
lover not just Danny Glover but Danny
Glover would be one of the people who
gets that money now this is something
the Democrats
pretend to it to oppose the idea taking
money from the poor and giving it to the
rich every time there's a tax cut for
rich people they say you're taking money
from the poor and giving it to the rich
which of course is not taking money from
the poor giving it to the rich that's
just allowing the rich to keep more of
their own money this would literally be
in many cases take taking money from the
poor and giving it to people who are
more well-off so here's a little bit of
what Danny Glover had to say a national
reparations policy is moral democratic
and economic imperative I sit here as
the great-great grandson of a former
slave Mary Brown who was freed by the
Emancipation Proclamation on January 1st
1863 despite much progress over the
centuries this hearing is yet another
important step in the long and heroic
struggle of african-americans secure
reparations for the damage is inflicted
by enslavement and post emancipation and
ratio exclusionary policies now the
writer Coleman Hughes also a black man
came out against reparations and he made
the point that this issue is distracting
from the real and current issues of
today nothing I'm about to say is meant
to minimize the horror and brutality of
slavery and Jim Crow racism is a bloody
stain on this country's history and I
consider our failure to pay reparations
directly to freed slaves after the Civil
War to be one of the greatest injustice
is ever perpetrated by the US government
but I worry that our desire to fix the
past compromises our ability to fix the
present think about what we're doing
today
we're spending our time debating a bill
that mentions slavery 25 times but
incarceration only once in an era with
no black slaves but nearly a million
black prisoners a bill that doesn't
mention homicide once
at a time when the Center for Disease
Control reports homicide as the number
one cause of death for young black men
I'm not saying that acknowledging
history doesn't matter it does I'm
saying there's a difference between
acknowledging history and allowing
history to distract us from the problems
we face today in 2008 the House of
Representatives formally apologized for
slavery and Jim Crow in 2009 the Senate
did the same black people don't need
another apology
we need safer neighborhoods and better
schools we need a less punitive criminal
justice system we need affordable health
care and none of these things can be
achieved through reparations for slavery
nearly everyone close to me
nearly everyone close to me told me not
to testify today they told me that even
though I've only ever voted for
Democrats I'd be perceived as a
Republican and therefore hated by half
the country others told me that by
distancing myself from Republicans I
would end up angering the other half of
the country and the sad truth is that
they were both right
that's how suspicious we've become of
one another
that's how divided we are as a nation if
we were to pay reparations today we
would only divide the country further
making it harder to build the political
coalition's required to solve the
problems facing black people today we
would insult many black Americans by
putting a price on the suffering of
their ancestors and we would turn the
relationship between black Americans and
white Americans from a coalition into a
transaction from a union between
citizens into a lawsuit between
plaintiffs and defendants what we should
do is pay reparations to black Americans
who actually grew up under Jim Crow and
were directly harmed by second-class
citizenship people like my grandparents
but paying reparations to all
descendants of slaves is a mistake take
me for example I was born three decades
after the
and of Jim Crow into a privileged
household in the suburbs I attend an Ivy
League school yet I'm also descended
from slaves who worked on Thomas
Jefferson's Monticello plantation so
reparations for slavery would allocate
federal resources to me but not to an
American with the wrong ancestry even if
that person is living paycheck to
paycheck and working multiple jobs to
support a family you might call that
justice
I call it justice for the dead at the
price of justice for the living I
understand that reparations are about
what people are owed regardless of how
well they're doing I understand that but
the people who are owed for slavery are
no longer here and we're not entitled to
collect on their debts reparations by
definition are only given to victims so
the moment you give me reparations
you've made me into a victim without my
consent
not just that you've made one third of
black Americans who pull against
reparations into victims without their
consent and black Americans have fought
too long for the right to define
themselves to be spoken for in such a
condescending manner the question is not
what America owes me by virtue of my
ancestry the question is what all
Americans owe each other by by virtue of
being citizens of the same nation and
the obligation of citizenship is not
transactional it's not contingent on
ancestry it never expires and it can't
be paid off for all these reasons bill
HR 40 is a moral and political mistake
thank you yeah it sounds like he's
making a good point there but Sheila
jackson-lee says that the issues of
today that Hughes mentions and the ones
that he says we need to be focused on
well she says that they're all the fault
of slavery anyway so you got to talk
about slavery because I'd all could be
traced back to slavery all the problems
in a black community
can be pinned on slavery she says 1
million African Americans are
incarcerated that is a continuing impact
the black employment rate is 6.6 percent
in spite of what has been said currently
more than double the national
unemployment rate 31 percent of black
children live in poverty compared to 11
percent of white children the national
average is 18 percent which suggested
the percentage of black children living
in poverty is more than 150 percent even
in spite of the glourious overcoming of
the talent that is part of our community
the scrapping together of making sure
our children received education the
putting together something out of
nothing
we still have been impacted and only 57
percent of black students have access
the full range of math and science
classes today
black children were vaccinated rates
lower than white children education
mobility has been limited black children
represent 19% of the nation's preschool
population yet 47% of those receiving
more than one out of school suspension
black students a 2.3 times as likely to
receive a referral to law enforcement so
she mentions a whole list of grievances
in there but but one just to highlight
one for a minute here
one of the grievances she mentions is
that black children are not vaccinated
as much as white children and this is
supposed to be because of slavery except
that if you want your kid to be
vaccinated and you bring them to the
doctor he'll be vaccinated nobody's
being refused vaccinations based on
their race that's not having if black
kids aren't getting vaccinated it's
because their parents aren't taking them
in to be vaccinated how in God's name
could that be the fault of slavery if
you as an individual parent make a
choice not to bring your kid to the
doctor how what does slavery have you
could've but you just didn't and so
that's your own choice now I'll be the
first to admit there is no denying of
course that obviously the black
community has been profoundly impacted
in a negative way by the history of
slavery and then and then even more so
because it's much more recent Jim Crow
right so there's no there's no denying
that but
and so we could have that conversation
that's a valuable conversation have the
only problem is that anytime Democrats
have that conversation they do two
things they want the conversation to
lead to taking money redistributing
money because that's what they're
obsessed with so it all has to it always
has to go there to the reader
redistribution of wealth as if that's
somehow gonna fix the problem when it
has not fixed the problem at all the
welfare state which has been going
strong now if we can call it strong for
many decades has not fixed this problem
it's only made it worse so that's the
first problems that they it's always
redistribution of wealth and then the
other problem is that they cast the net
it's just way too big of a net they cast
they they they go way too far with it to
the point where rather than talking in
you know in a sort of general sense
about the the situation of blackvue they
try to get into the specifics things
that are clearly just the result of
individual choices like the the
fatherless problem in the black
community well I guess Sheila
jackson-lee would tell us that that also
is uh is the fault of slavery except
that no those are those what happens
there you have individual men black men
in this case who choose to impregnate
women and then not stick around to raise
them it's a choice that they make didn't
have to make that choice but they do
same for there's also an increasing
fatherless problem in the white
community to this this is a this is a
cultural problem statistically it's much
worse than a black community but it's a
it's a big problem in the white
community too in all communities and
there it's the same thing you you don't
matter what race you are you choose to
make kids and not stick around for them
that's your choice you didn't have to
choose that you did so the you know your
your the history of your race or your
culture has nothing to do with with your
own personal choice in that case alright
um now for a dose of sanity in these
proceedings representative Mike Johnson
tried to explain why the idea of
reparations is illegal and
unconstitutional but notice as he lays
out his reasonable fact-based case he
gets booed by the crowd what's this
Barack Obama opposed reparations when he
ran for president
2008 and Hillary Clinton and Bernie
Sanders did as well eight years later in
addition to all this here in the
Judiciary Committee we have an
obligation to acknowledge that any
monetary reparations that might be
recommended by the Commission created by
HR 41 constitutional on their face the
reason for that listen wait a minute
the reason for that is a legal question
see the legal question is the federal
government can't constitutionally
provide compensation today to a specific
racial group because other members of
that group may be several generations
ago were discriminated against and
treated inhumanely according to the US
Supreme Court they would refer to that
as an unconstitutional racial preference
see if the holding of the 1995 case
richmond vga cross and company is that
racial set asides and other entitlements
are only permission constitutionally
permissible to remedy the present
affects of the government's own
widespread in recent discrimination and
the federal government is not allowed to
provide race-based remedies that are
quote ageless in their region of the
past and timeless and their ability to
affect the future unquote okay so there
you go and and everything you said there
is it's true but he gets booed for it
because you're not allowed to make any
reasonable points at a hearing like this
now I'm gonna try to break down why this
is such a terrible and absurd idea but
first before we get to let that let's
check in with dynatrap you know it's
summer and the only thing more annoying
than pointless hearings on Capitol Hill
are flies and other insects inside your
home and who knows where those where
those flies were last you know they
could have been they could have landed
on a on a pile of dung somewhere and now
they're landing on your sandwich we
we've got a problem in this house
because our kids and anyone who has
little kids in the house you know that
they they're - there are two things
they're incapable of doing little kids
they're incapable of keeping their shoes
on they will take their shoes off no
matter where they are you know you know
you just you you arrive at a location
thirty seconds later their shoes are off
and lost - that's irrelevant
second thing that are capable of doing
is keeping the door shut the outside
door they'll just stay any time they
walk outside they can never for some
they're incapable just shutting it so
the door so our doors and
are always open and then flies are
coming in so this is a problem for us
which is why we'd like to thank our
sponsors over dynatrap dynatrap is the
leading manufacturer of outdoor mosquito
and insect traps and now they've come up
with a solution for indoor pests the
dynatrap fly like the dynatrap fly light
works day and night to attract and trap
flies fruit flies mosquitoes other pesky
insects and it really works I've been
using dynatrap fly light myself for a
few weeks now and it has definitely been
controlling the ongoing problem that my
kids keep creating when they leave the
door open but fortunately the dynatrap
fly light takes care of it so and it's a
lot better by the way the most crude
primitive you know contraptions with a
sticky sticky tape that the fly goes on
it's and this is a lot better than that
you can get yours today at dynatrap calm
that's Dyn ATR AP calm and to the promo
code walsh and receive 15% off any of
their products dynatrap the safe silent
simple solution to household insect
control alright so there are basically
two GATT categories of wrongness when it
comes to reparations in my mind
reparations are morally wrong and also
practically impossible so let me explain
both morally wrong this is really the
main point I think we can begin and end
the conversation right here it is simply
a moral abomination to punish people for
the sins of their distant relatives this
is a basic principle that all civilized
societies must affirm if they want to be
civilized society you cannot reward or
punish people based on events that took
place generations ago it's a very basic
thing events that did not directly
involve anyone who's alive today if I if
I broke into your house let's say and
stole cash out of your sock drawer where
everybody keeps their cash for some
reason and then you broke into my house
to steal it back well you probably still
would be breaking the law but morally
speaking I think you're entirely
justified you're taking back what is
yours you are writing the wrong and I
certainly have no room but I can't
complain about that can i but
if my great-great-great-great
great-grandfather broke into your
great-great-great great-great
grandfather's house and stole his money
out of his sock drawer then obviously
you would be nothing but a thief if you
broke into my house and stole money out
of my sock drawer in restitution for the
simple reason that I didn't do it okay
that you know that's that's that's a
very very basic concept here I'm not the
one who did it the fact that I'm related
in a very distant way to the guy who did
so what it's the same reason that if
somebody goes out and kills another
person you know if J if John goes out
and kills Bob
we don't put John's brother in jail for
it unless John's brother was an
accomplice but if he was just out you
know across the country minding his
business when I haven't it'll punish him
he didn't do it yeah he might be related
to the guy but he didn't do it so that
money in this can this analogy where
you're still that money is mine it's not
yours I didn't take it from you I wasn't
the perpetrator you were not the victim
but now you you now are the perpetrator
and I'm the victim in an effort to right
the past wrong you have just created a
new wrong that must now be righted okay
but what if you could demonstrate that
my great-great grandfather's thieving
behavior caused such a devastating
effect on your great great grandfather
that it's reverberating through the ages
and now your family is in a much worse
spot today than they would have been had
that that Seth never took place and
that's possible you know the butterfly
effect the butterfly flaps his wings and
in New York and there's a there's a
tsunami you know in the Pacific Ocean
which I don't think it really works that
way but that's the whole idea
it's certainly generationally there is
something like a butterfly effect that
takes place but even so that doesn't
just at this what if game well if that
hadn't happened it okay well what if
they maybe maybe they if my great great
great great grandfather never stolen the
money you know maybe things
be different that's true but that
doesn't justify you victimizing me to
add more injustice will not write that
injustice now if we were today to go to
bring it back to what we're talking
about reparations for slavery if we work
today only five years removed from the
abolition of slavery or ten years or
even thirty years removed and we were
talking about reparations I would say
yeah absolutely but 150 years six
generations no but there are many
practical problems here as well and so
that's the moral issue that you're
punishing someone for something they
didn't do pretty simple and that's wrong
but there are practical problems as well
which also you could begin and end the
conversation here because it's just
impossible to sort through these I'm
going to try to highlight those
practical problems with just some
questions some questions that I don't
think we're covered in the hearing and
that the advocates for reparations never
seem to address but here my questions
all right number one what about black
Americans whose families came to America
after abolition do they get paid
number two what about white Americans
whose families came here after abolition
do they have to pay number three what
about Native Americans Native Americans
who owned slaves
what about black people who owned slaves
do their so their descendants pay or get
paid now it was of course much much
rarer for for a black person to own
slaves but there were some black people
on site don't we need to figure out who
they're related to so we can we
certainly can't pay them restitution can
we number 4 what about black people who
descend from the tribal chiefs to
chieftains in Africa who sold the slaves
to white traders do they pay or get paid
it seems to me we'd have to sort that
out and figure that out because remember
slavery first of all was a worldwide and
universal institution for thousands of
years the north
American slave trade specifically was
something that was was was obviously we
had the the interactions the
transactions that happen in North North
America but there were also transactions
that happened in Africa and in many of
those cases you had Africans selling
other Africans and slave into slavery
which is an abominable evil as well
clearly five what about non black people
who what about you know any any anyone
any non blacks who were whose ancestors
were slaves in other countries think
about Jews in Egypt whites on the
Barbary Coast for example do they still
have to pay now I know you could say
well but they were slaves somewhere else
and so it doesn't well so what who cares
if they were slaves somewhere else they
they still are it still happened
you could still argue that their
families are affected by it you could
argue that their culture their race
their ethnicity has been affected by it
the reverberations of it and if we're if
we're reaching back a hundred and fifty
years then I don't see a problem with
reaching across into a different country
what's the difference I mean either way
we're dealing with stuff that didn't
happen recently and isn't happening now
so if we're doing that then I then why
don't we bring these other things into a
into play or what about what about
people who were whose families were
persecuted and victimized in other ways
think about how the Irish were
persecuted by the British think about
again Jews I mean think about think
about Jewish people who's you know
grandparents were murdered in the
Holocaust do you think the you know the
situation of Jews today would be
different if not for the Holocaust I
think so
six what about someone whose
great-great-great-great
great-grandfather was a slave owner and
great-great-great great-grandmother a
slave there are plenty of examples of
that is that someone
to pay himself number seven how do we
know exactly who is descended from who
how are we gonna figure this out
mandatory DNA tests I guess we have to
there have to be a national initiative
forcing everyone to get a DNA test so we
can figure out who is the set of remote
8 even if we could know what about slave
descendants who are wealthy today like
Danny Glover and slave owner descendents
were in poverty would the poor have to
pay the rich and number 9 weren't things
like affirmative action already supposed
to address this issue would someone who
got into college from affirmative action
still get paid so they end up getting
reparations twice affirmative action was
supposed to address the the supposed
institutional biases in the that that's
you know still still happening in our
society so now we're gonna have double
reparations so just a few questions and
those are questions that I think are
those are those are questions that are
unanswerable and problems that cannot be
solved there's no way you could sort
through all of that in order to make
this happen so it's just practically
impossible and absurd all right um I
want to mention this the Cleveland
Clinic announced yesterday that it's
successfully completed its first in
utero operation to repair spina bifida
in an unborn child and the surgery is
just I mean I was I was reading a
description of it involves a spectacular
combination of advanced technology and
surgical scale in fact here's um here's
a description provided by the Cleveland
Clinic of how this mis works just
because I find it very fascinating says
during the fetal repair surgery a
cesarean section like incision is made
and the mother's uterus is exposed and
ultrasound is then used to locate the
placenta and fetus the uterus is opened
four point five centimeters and the back
of the fetus is exposed showing the
spina bifida lesion the surgeons
then carefully suture several individual
layers of tissue in order to cover the
defect after the uterus is closed back
up the fetus remains in the woman for
the remainder of the pregnancy and is
ultimately born by cesarean section I
mean this is it's amazing that they can
do that it really is amazing and this
procedure is not unprecedented the I saw
this on social media yesterday it's a
first I'd ever heard of I didn't know
that they could do this that they could
treat spina bifida in the womb now it's
not a cure right so they're not at the
point yet where they can cure it where a
baby who has this defect will be will
you know be born and will have no signs
of whatsoever but they can drastically
reduce the effects and they can
hopefully make it so that for instance
the child will eventually be able to
walk on his own and that sort of thing
whereas otherwise he wouldn't be able to
but this is not entirely unprecedented
Children's Hospital of Pittsburgh had
its own first surgery of this kind a
couple of months ago and it's all part
of a relatively new and burgeoning
branch of medicine fetal surgery which
as the first example of that was back in
the 80s but it's expanded a lot
especially recently and it's become more
common in recent years as the technology
has just rapidly improved and today I
was looking at a list on the Children's
Hospital of Philadelphia x' website and
they've got a list of a whole host of
conditions that I won't read because I
can't pronounce a lot of them but a
whole host of conditions that can be
treated by fetal surgery spina bifida
just being one of them and more added to
the list every year meanwhile when you
consider thinking about this and then
think about how the technological
advancements have also precipitously
lowered the age of quote viability for
an unborn child a couple of years ago a
baby was born at 21 weeks and survived
and today she's a healthy toddler
running around and having no problems in
extremely premature birth used to be a
death sentence but today babies born
before the tried the third trimester
routinely survived the baby born at 23rd
24th 25th week
most of those babies will survive them
and there's no reason to think we've
reached our limit I think eventually
we're going to get to a point where
there will not be a non-viable
gestational age I think eventually we
get to a point where a human life can be
extracted from the womb at any point and
put into essentially an artificial womb
which is which is basically what they do
if you've ever been to a NICU in the
intensive care unit for the natal
intensive care unit for babies that are
born very prematurely my own our
children the twins were born prematurely
they weren't born that prematurely they
were born just a few weeks before before
term but they spend 24 hours in the in
the NICU and you go up there and it's
it's just it's not something you ever
forget being in a NICU of a hospital but
anyway what you see is that they
essentially put these babies in kind of
an artificial womb in a way so they can
continue to grow and develop and get to
a healthy point where they can breathe
on their own and all that kind of stuff
I think that technology to create these
artificial womb life conditions
we'll get to will continue to develop
and who knows twenty years from now or
whatever we'll be at a point where you
know at five weeks you could take the
baby out and put it into and it will
still survive now this is all quite
inspiring and wonderful and incredible
unless right
you're pro-abortion these revolutions in
medical technology are rendering the
case for abortion more and more obsolete
by the minute and things have been
trending that way for a long time ever
since they did the first ultrasound back
in the 50s and you could actually see
now for the first time it's hard for us
to even to sort of imagine this but of
course up until that point when a woman
was pregnant
there was you know for thousands of
years women were getting pregnant and we
there was no way to see what was
happening inside there or to know
exactly what a baby looks like at that
age at any particular point well with
ultrasound technology you can look in
it's a window into the womb and you can
see that yes these little humans in the
womb are indeed little humans and they
look like it too so ever since then the
case for abortion is becoming more and
more obsolete and that that process is
just increasing rapidly in recent years
as we've seen this just technology take
off and the the introduction of fetal
surgery yet again affirms this truth
that those are little human beings in
the womb not clumps of cell cells
doctors would not be able to treat spina
bifida in a clump of cells they would
not be able to repair a birth defect in
an inhuman mass of material they could
only do it they could only conduct these
delicate and complicated procedures
because the patients are living human
beings and the claim that abortion is
necessary has also suffered devastating
blows recently of course even without
these medical Marvel's abortion could
never be considered actually necessary
it's never necessary to directly kill an
innocent human life but that's all the
more the case now that any number of
field defects and abnormalities can be
treated and also the health of the
mother justifications don't really work
as well as they used to not that they
ever really worked because at any point
from the middle of the second trimester
on if the woman suffers a cataclysmic
complication she can deliver the baby
and the baby will still survive there's
no reason to kill the baby this is the
position in which Pro boards find
themselves rooting against life saving
scientific advancements and this from
the compassionate pro science crowd
right right
um alright we will at one other video
clip I wanted to play but I think I'll
save that for tomorrow
and we'll go to emails Matt well show at
gmail.com Matt well show at gmail.com
this is from Hanna says I heard you
reading all the positive reviews for
your scrambled eggs recipe and felt it
necessary to chime in I really did want
it to work I wanted to enjoy fluffy
scrambled eggs but I just couldn't
handle them I'll concede that maybe
being eight weeks pregnant and fighting
morning sickness had something to do
with it so for future reference perhaps
you should get it give a disclaimer with
your recipes not recommended for
nauseous pregnant ladies maybe I'll find
the courage to try them again in a few
months my husband and I enjoy your show
thanks for all that you do well I'll
have you know Hannah that my wife is
pregnant and I have made her my
delicious scrambled eggs and she enjoys
them so how dare you try to use
pregnancy as an excuse for not liking my
scrambled eggs recipe how dare you
alright this is from Reverend Larry says
exalted mr. Walsch I exhort you to
augment your lexicon with a more
accurate label of birth supremacist when
referring to Pro abortionists since they
frequently lump conservatives and
Christians in with white supremacist
bigots they're being on the receiving
end of the supremacist label will serve
as an annoying rhetorical rhetorical
barrier to their denial of their own
murderous bigotry something of which I
believe we have a moral obligation to
admit you [ __ ] alii remind them PS am I
never to be humble and non hyperbolic
opinion the most clever article ever
written in the history of mankind is
yours is your please stop killing
undocumented infants who are trying to
cross the border of the birth canal
article sincerely Reverend Larry well I
appreciate that and speaking of clever I
think birth supremacist is is good I
like that I might I might take that and
run with it I am as I've said many times
that the left there the most
use tool in their toolbox is the
manipulation of language rather than
making an argument they just come up
with a different label the different
terms or whatever it is they're trying
to they're trying to justify or fight
against and they do that in lieu of
making arguments why I think we should
we should i do believe also we should
give them a dose of their own medicine
we should use that against them and so
that's a great idea i like that this is
from jeffrey says you spent five to ten
minutes talking about how the culture is
bad because people want to follow OJ
Simpson on Twitter and see all the crazy
the day before you literally subjected
your entire audience to one of Taylor
Swift's most atrocious songs she's crazy
and her songs are trash that you played
this abomination for us I admit that I
enjoyed agreeing with you about how she
only makes the same boring anti hater
songs over and over but the very next
day you come out and talk about how
people shouldn't be going looking for
more crazy and stupid seriously and you
actually followed up the don't go
looking for stupid and crazy segments
with a segment about some crazy stupid
egotistical psychopath who has to make
up word because of how much better than
everyone else she is by being an LGBTQ
woke scold I was honestly waiting for
you to drop a sarcastic punch line
somewhere connecting the two segments
because I thought that level that level
of hypocrisy was reserved for comedy if
we can't follow or pay attention to
stupid and crazy than aoc is clearly no
longer a potential topic hardly any
Democrats are probably not the president
either everyone has different opinions
on what is acceptable crazy and stupid
to pay attention to okay so I think
I think Jeff I did I did actually I did
I did think about that the the seeming
hypocrisy that you mentioned because I
was talking about how people are
following LJ on Twitter because they
want immediate access to the stupid and
crazy that he puts out and I was saying
how unhealthy and pointless that is and
then my very next segment was about I
think it was about the yeah it's about
the trans poet whose rearranging the
alphabet because the normal alphabet
isn't good enough for him which is both
stupid and crazy so what gives how can I
bring up stupid and crazy stuff if I'm
saying that we should pay less attention
to stupid and crazy stuff well the
answer is maybe I am a hypocrite on that
front it's it's that's perfectly
possible so that could be it but I would
also suggest that what I try to do with
this show and with my writing is wade
into the stupid and crazy which is
usually not an enjoyable thing for me
and then bring it to your attention and
and but in order to find the point to
find the lesson that we can learn from
it what I don't want to do is just hit
you over the head with it have you like
bask in it and then leave you there in
the midst of the stupid and crazy I
don't want to do that I want to get to
the point I want to get to a conclusion
the problem is when we do sort of just
bask in the stupid and crazy just for
the sake of it when we consume it
instinctively unthinkingly for purposes
of entertainment or distraction that's
where I think it becomes a problem like
when you watch your when you sit down
and watch three hours of reality shows
where the only real attraction the only
entertainment value is just that these
people are being stupid and crazy well
then then your basket there's no point
to it you're probably not thinking much
about it you're not sitting there
analyzing it you're probably not writing
a thesis about it you're just basking in
it you're just dwelling in it you're
you're you're enjoying it is the point
and I think that's where it becomes
unhealthy there is a there is a balance
here
because there's a lot of stupid and
crazy out there some of which has no
effect on our lives some of some of some
of it does though and so we can't ignore
it we can't just put our blinders aren't
in charge ahead and pretend that we're
not living in the society that we are we
can't do that but at the same time we
don't want to dive into it and just
start doing kind of back strokes and and
and making ourselves comfortable right
so I think that's the balance and I try
to strike that balance I probably don't
always do a perfect job of it so you're
right about that and I also think as I
said I I consider it part of my job as
part of my job to pay attention to this
stuff you know I offer cultural analysis
as a job that's what I do for a living
right and so I do have to pay attention
to this stuff I mean I have to be on
Twitter people think it's a joke cause
it's a part of my job it really is
actually part of my job I have to be
there I wish I didn't and so that's why
I often say to people like if if this
wasn't my job if I did something else
for a living you know if I just if I
worked at an office complex somewhere or
anything if I did anything else whatever
the job is if it had nothing to do with
media at all nothing to do with offering
commentary nothing to do with forming
opinions about society if I had some
other kind of job I personally I would
not I wouldn't be on Facebook I wouldn't
be on Twitter I would spend very little
time on the Internet
I probably wouldn't even have it on my
phone I would I would just I would spend
my free time outside I would you know i
don't i would read more books i would do
other things that have nothing to do
with this because it's it's
it's exhausting it's draining it just
sucks the life force out of you and so
that's why I encourage people and I'm
not not trying to be a hypocrite
but if you don't have to be here if you
don't have to be online all the time you
don't have to be on social media all the
time if you don't have to be surrounded
by this craziness all the time then then
don't be I think you know really I think
you a lot happier and just you'll have a
much more joyful and enjoyable life if
you're not always surrounded by the
stuff if you don't have to be alright um
so that's my little recommendation for
the day my pro tip for the day and I
guess we'll leave it there thanks
everybody for watching thanks for
listening Godspeed
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show Americans have
been breaking chains for nearly 250
years we broke the chains of southern
slavery the chains of Jim Crow the
chains of Nazism the chains of communism
it's time for us to rise up as one and
break some new change the mental chains
of identity politics and political
correctness that's on the last Andrew
Clavin show before the Clavin last week
you don't want to miss it
I'm Andrew Clavin